mais le dépêche datée de 21h34 cet état
de ce que des garde-frontière
est-allemand commencé d'ouvrir des muses
des brèches pardon dans le mur de berlin
pour y aménager des points de passages
supplémentaires depuis hier soir 19h
neuf en tout cas heures de la première
ouverture du mur de berlin
une centaine de milliers d'est allemands
se sont précipités à l'ouest où il
n'avait pas pu mettre les pieds depuis
28 ans très vite les services de visa
mise en place ce matin ont été débordés
et chacun passe librement inimaginable
aussi la retransmission pratiquement en
direct de tous ces événements à la
télévision est-allemande des images
bouleversantes sans aucun précédent et
que sans aucun précédent non plus et
télévisions du monde entier ont pu
filmer librement et l'inde risacher et
ambroise perrin sont sur place à berlin
ils ont vécu pour nous cette folle nuit
d'ivresse à 16h45 ce matin premier coup
de pioche sur le mur de berlin des
dizaines d'allemands est et ouest sont
montés sur le monument historique la
zone interdite est thomas de la jeunesse
allemande
chacun leur tour ils prennent la pioche
casse un morceau du mur qu'ils gardent
dans leur poche en souvenir
le cadenas est cassé et les portes
s'ouvrent vers 23h l'année dernière des
milliers d'allemands de l'est ont forcé
les frontières qui séparent à l'est et
l'ouest
les gardes-frontières n'interviennent
pas
en théorie les services de police de rda
devait vérifier les papiers de cette
foule très vite débordé il renonce
certains d'allemands de l'est incrédule
devant cette liberté accordée si
brutalement hésite plusieurs minutes
avant d'oser franchir la frontière et là
sur le pont de banderoles moeurs 28 ans
après les deux côtés se retrouvent
à pied en vélo en voiture travail
ceux de l'est entre à l'ouest leur
liberté totale
on offre du champagne et du coca et
pendant ce temps des allemands de
l'ouest passe à leur tour sans bise à
berlin est juste pour vérifier que c'est
bien possible jusqu'à présent les
allemands de l'ouest en effet devait
attendre un visa de 48 heures à six
semaines
incroyable
comment on dit en france ratha midi
libre ni d égalité et je croise revient
ici aussi
moi je suis obligée de rester ici
quand on travaille on travaille jusqu'à
l'aube
les allemands de l'est ont envahi les
rues de berlin ouest ils veulent voir et
berlin avec redevient berlin c'est
incroyable c'est la première fois que je
viens ici mais après je rentre à l'aise
parce que mes enfants sont à la maison à
3 heures du matin embouteillages
monstres dans le centre de berlin ouest
oui c'est beau et puis on est libre il
vient de la loppsi 2 ce matin à 7h on
retourne au travail
on a entendu la nouvelle à la radio et
voilà on est venu à cette incroyable
moi je n'ai jamais vu de choses comme ça
nous voulons juste regarder tout ce qui
est là après on rentre
je n'ai jamais jamais on ne reviendra à
singer partie leur ferment pour toujours
cette famille était hier soir une
exception les allemands de l'est
la nuit dernière et aujourd'hui encore
veulent se prouver que c'est possible
désormais ils peuvent aller à l'ouest
même faut une simple promenade